zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
am sonntagmorgen unserer zeit ist es
soweit dann wird sich mit matthias
maurer der insgesamt vierte deutsche
astronaut auf den weg machen zur
internationalen raumstation iss auch das
werden wir live zeigen bei heute live
aber vorher heute abend wollen wir zur
einstimmung schon mit dem mann sprechen
der als bislang letzter deutscher auf
der internationalen raumstation
gearbeitet hat nämlich mit astro alex
oder wer eigentlich heißt alexander
gerst das ganze in wenigen minuten zuvor
schalten wir jetzt aber zu unserer
kollegin susanne freitag in die usa sie
ist nämlich schon vor ort in florida
genauer gesagt am coco beach in der nähe
des kennedy space center in cape
canaveral wo dann am sonntag eben die
rakete von launchpad 39a abheben wird
einen schönen guten tag susanne
ja hallo wir sind gut aus bei euch in
florida du hast mir gesagt es ist schön
warm also das wetter scheint
mitzuspielen vielleicht gleich nochmal
die einschätzung was tut sich im moment
fort es ist jetzt freitag mittag also
zwei tage sozusagen vor dem start gibt
es das schon so eine art positive
nervosität merkt man schon so ein
bisschen aufgeregte betriebsamkeit wenn
ich das jetzt bei dir so sehe da haben
sich die leute ihren liegestuhl genommen
das sieht alles noch relativ entspannt
aus
ja das ist relativ entspannt das wird es
sicherlich auch bleiben aber man merkt
schon diese positive erwartungshaltung
weil hier natürlich schon viele zeichen
darauf hindeuten dass das hier bald
losgeht die rakete wurde gestern schon
hochgezogen man hat bilder gesehen von
spacex also man weiß es geht wirklich
bald los und anfang der woche ist
matthias maurer mit seinem team hier her
gekommen und hat noch mal eine kurze ein
kurzes presse statement abgegeben und
man merkte auch bei den astronauten da
ist eine wirklich freudige erwartung da
weil es jetzt endlich losgeht nachdem
sich alle jahre lang vorbereitet haben
na ja und hier am coco beach wir stehen
hier mitten auf der sogenannten space
coast also der weltraum küste weil sich
hier eigentlich alles um den weltraum
dreht wenn man hier mal hinguckt da
hinten man sieht gebäude und so so
pfeiler die da in den himmel ragen das
sind die abschussrampen von cape
canaveral das ist also auch der strand
von dem man einen super blick hat wenn
man raketenstart beobachten will das
machen hier auch viele leute hier werden
am starttag oder in der stadt macht muss
man besser sagen bis zu hunderttausend
schaulustige erwartet die extra für
diese raketenstart zum teil auch
kilometer weit hierher fahren da gibt es
plätze da stehen leute mit wohnmobilen
um sich das alles an zu gucken weil das
hier einfach eine region ist die von
diesem weltraum business einfach auch
lebt viele hotels sind einfach voll wenn
diese wenn diese veranstaltungen
stattfinden und auch hier in der
umgebung sind inzwischen sehr sehr viele
wissenschaftler eingetroffen die
natürlich mit beobachten was passiert
mit unseren astronauten auch viele
deutsche wissenschaftler sind hier vom
dlr von der esa die den astronauten
matthias maurer hier bis zur startrampe
begleiten bevor er ins all fliegt und da
merkt man schon wie groß die
begeisterung auch ist im vorfeld weil
diese leute haben jahrelang an
experimenten gearbeitet die jetzt mit
nach oben fliegen beziehungsweise schon
oben sind die zum teil auch schon seit
jahren da oben sind und weitergeführt
werden also man spürt hier so eine
richtige wissenschafts begeisterung und
alle fiebern jetzt so ein bisschen auf
diesen tag hin oder diese nacht muss man
ja sagen weil es wird hier finster sein
und man hat uns gesagt dass diesen acht
starts ganz besonders beeindruckend sein
sollen weil dann der himmel sich
plötzlich erhält also ich glaube schon
dass es da was zu sehen das kann man
sich lebhaft vorstellen dass das
bestimmt sehr interessant ist dass zu
beobachten dann auch aus nächster nähe
wir sehen ein bisschen wind bei dir der
wetter oder das wetter ist ja auch immer
so einen ein faktor bei so sachen es gab
auch schon verschiebungen in der
vergangenheit auch jetzt bei diesem
start gab es einmal ein hin und her wie
ist momentan die einschätzung was sagen
die meteorologen
also im moment haben wir keine hinweise
darauf dass der staat nicht pünktlich
beginnen soll es finden aber regelmäßige
wetter briefings stadt und sohn
raketenstart wird natürlich nur dann
durchgeführt wenn alle bedingungen
hundertprozentig
günstig sind um diesen staat auch sicher
durchzuführen denn man will ja dass
alles gut funktioniert und
im moment also für uns ist das wetter
jetzt perfekt und im moment scheint es
auch für den raketenstart zu sein
wunderbar susanne dann hoffen wir dass
es so bleibt ganz lieben dank für diese
eindrücke von vor ort wir sprechen also
gleich mit alexander gerst an der
gleichen stelle und bevor wir mit ihm
sprechen wollen wir noch mal kurz rein
hören was sein designierter nachfolger
was matthias maurer zwei tage vor dem
start sozusagen heute noch mal zu sagen
hatte das jetzt
gestern abend war ich zum allerersten
mal mit meinen kollegen dann in der
kapsel auf der spitze der schon
aufgerichteten rakete am stadtplatz und
dass das war schon so ein moment wo ich
nach der das wird jetzt doch langsam
richtig echt
startplatz steigen wir dann in die
rakete ein wir haben dann auch hilfe von
den teams die uns da so richtig dann
feststellen festzurren in der kapsel
dann führen ein paar checks durch
hauptsächlich kommunikations checks dann
werden die sitze das sind ja zum
einsteigen haben wir die lande position
man bequem einsteigen die werden dann
nach hinten geklappt und sobald wir dann
in dieser position sind gehen die teams
hin schließen die seiten luke zu dort
liegt checks geben und dann knapp 40
minuten vom start wird das automatische
es krebs system also das longboard
system dann scharf geschaltet dann
beginnt auch das tanken und sobald das
danken fertig ist ist der countdown auch
an dem punkt wo wir dann starten können
dann hoffe ich dass dann ein bilderbuch
nacht statt haben
ja genau das hoffen wir auch das hoffen
wir alle
da bekommen wir unser zu unserem zweiten
gesprächspartner den wir da gab es schon
im hintergrund sehen nämlich zu
alexander gas ich sah vielleicht gerade
vorher noch ein paar takte zu denen er
flog sogar zweimal mit der sojus kapsel
zur iss übernahm als erster deutscher
astronaut das kommando auf der
raumstation mit seinen zwei
weltraummissionen erreichte der erst
eine gesamt aufenthaltsdauer von 362
tagen im weltall ist damit rekordhalter
der esa er ist studierter geophysiker
und vulkanologe und kann uns als
versierter raumfahrern um die mission
von matthias maurer noch ein bisschen
näher bringen auch ein mit ihm sprechen
wir in cape canaveral also unweit der
startposition der rakete die dann am
sonntag ab leben wird einen schönen
guten tag nach von anna herzlich
willkommen alexander gerst
direkt vor cape canaveral wir haben
gerade gesehen es ist sehr schönes
wetter her sehr geil wunderbar also da
bin laden wir sie ein wenig sie haben
mit natürlich auch einen tollen platz
dann um den staat zu beobachten können
wir vielleicht gleich noch drüber
sprechen sind sie ein bisschen neidisch
auf matthias maurer dass der jetzt am
sonntag fliegen darf und sie nicht
ja die frage gehe ich natürlich jetzt
aufgestellt zuallererst muss ich sagen
freue ich mich total dass ein kollege
und freund von mir jetzt starten kann
wir kennen uns ja schon lange wir haben
zusammen trainiert und ich bin wirklich
froh dass er jetzt zusammen auch mit
dieser tollen crew baut ihr seinen traum
wahr machen kann und zur iss los starten
kann das ist toll aber sie haben
natürlich recht als astronaut fühlt man
sich zwar immer sehr wohl auf jeglichem
raketenstartplatz aber ich würde lügen
wenn ich nicht sagen würde ich würde
auch fast denn da drehen zu sitzen diese
rakete aber ich hab es schon zwei mal
gemacht und deswegen ist jetzt einfach
mal an der zeit dass matthias fliegt und
da freue ich mich wirklich sehr darüber
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu der frage
warum sie jetzt vor ort sind sie sind
teil der isa delegation oder wie muss
man sich das vorstellen
ja genau ich bin zwar der operationellen
gruppe kollegin hat es ja schon gesagt
das sind gerade viele leute vor ort die
die mission unterstützen
im flight control room
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
kollegen von der presse auch die familie
nicht zuletzt da ist es wichtig dass man
mit denen auch in engen kontakt bleibt
dass man den auch erklären kann was da
im hintergrund abläuft das ist ja neu
für die meisten von ihnen und da ist es
ganz gut wenn wenn sie mit jemand
sprechen können jetzt schon mal mit
durchgemacht hat da kann man auch so ein
bisschen beruhigen und einfach so als
stabiles element da sein bevor wir
weiter sprechen wollen wir uns
vielleicht noch mal kurz anschauen herr
gast wie dieser flug dann am sonntag
eigentlich ablaufen wird dazu haben wir
mal einen kleinen beitrag vorbereitet
das kennedy space center an der küste
von florida von hier geht es los ein
geschichtsträchtiger ort denn von hier
sind auch schon die apollo-astronauten
vor über 50 jahren das erste mal zum
mond aufgebrochen mit einer kollegin und
zwei kollegen steigt matthias maurer in
einer crew dragon kapsel auf der spitze
einer 70 meter hohen rakete die
fernandez privatanbieter spacex bis
teilweise wieder verwendbar und besteht
aus zwei stufen die erste stufe
katapultiert die rakete die ersten
minuten nach oben dann koppelte sich vom
rest ab und landet wieder auf einer
schwimmenden plattform im ozean sie kann
für einen nächsten start wieder fit
gemacht werden die zweite stufe der
rakete beschleunigt die dragon kapsel
weiter auf eine umlauf geschwindigkeit
von 28.000 kilometer die stunde und das
sind weniger als zehn minuten dann
trennt sich die kapsel vom zweiten teil
der rakete
400 kilometer ist die internationale
raumstation von der erde entfernt aber
im all an gelangt heißt noch nicht
angedockt an die iss die kuh unternimmt
eine vielzahl an manövern um der iss
immer näher zu kommen
von start bis doping vergehen etwa 22
stunden nach einer reihe von tests bei
denen zb der druck kontrolliert wird
kann die luke geöffnet werden die
astronauten sind endlich auf der iss
und die kuh dragon kapsel mit der
gelangt maurer später wieder zurück zur
erde auch die kapsel kann danach für
eine weitere mission wiederverwendet
werden
ja herr gäste sind ja damals noch mit
einer sojus kapsel ins all gestartet die
aktuelle crew wird also mit der firma
von elon musk mit spacex ins all
geflogen ist das jetzt so ein bisschen
flapsig gesagt leider gegen tesla ist
der unterschied am ende gar nicht so
groß was dann das reiseerlebnis bzw den
komfort vielleicht auch an bord angeht
ja uns ist erst mal der komfort ein
bisschen weniger wichtig als die
sicherheit und da hat die sojus
natürlich einen an eine phänomenale
geschichte einfach weiß ich schon so
lange existiert das bedeutet aber eben
auch das ist jetzt natürlich irgendwann
auch neuere systeme geben wird das basic
system ist eins davon und das muss man
einfach so sehen das ist einfach eine
neue generation das raumschiff ist es
ist größer komfortabler sie am strengen
gesagt und es hat aber eben auch eine
andere philosophie dahinter was die
steuerung angeht die sojus war noch sehr
manuell die astronauten mussten mit
beiden händen die joystick steuern um
die kapsel anzudocken wenn das
automatische system ausfiel das ist
jetzt heute viel automatischer geregelt
bei der space sex also das ist schon
einfach einen schritt nach vorn ich
würde ihn mit beiden kapseln einfach
ohne bedenken fliegen das hat natürlich
vor und nachteile immer also ein so
neues system ist noch nicht ganz so
getestet man weiß noch nicht genau was
die risiken sind da gibt es vielleicht
auch noch verborgenen risiken aber das
ist eben was man eingehen muss aber auf
jeden fall ist das der weg nach vorn und
von allem was ich von meinen kollegen
höre auch von thomas kaiser kollege der
er gerade auf der raumstation iss mit
der kultur ist das sind alles weg wir
haben es gerade im beitrag gehört die
flugzeit zum andocken beträgt rund 22
stunden wie kompliziert ist so ein flug
für die crew und wo sind da vielleicht
die besonders riskanten kniffligen
stellen
der flug wird eigentlich relativ
automatisch sein das heißt die crew
muss das natürlich überwachen
hauptsächlich die die astronauten die
amerikanische astronautin dem fall die
die piloten sind da müssen sie immer
wieder ein auge drauf werfen dass alle
zündung der triebwerke
gut laufen dann muss ich immer
zwischendrin auch wieder das triebwerk
angeschaltet werden wieder ausgeschaltet
werden aber letztendlich funktioniert
das wegen relativ automatisch das heißt
in den 22 stunden geht es darum für die
crew sich an die weltraum bedingungen zu
gewöhnen und schwerelosigkeit essen zu
sich zu nehmen noch einmal zu schlafen
um dann fit zu sein für die ankunft an
der raumstation dass man mal so eine
dynamische phase wo man sich schon gut
drauf konzentrieren muss und deswegen
ist es gut sich da vorher zu erholen das
war bei uns bei der sojus ähnlich wie
beim normalen fliegen sagt man ja oft so
start und landung sind so ein bisschen
die neuralgischen punkte jetzt kann man
sich ja vorstellen wenn man dann da
sitzt in dieser rakete und man weiß man
man sitzt da buchstäblich auf tausenden
von tonnen treibstoff und da muss man
mal irgendein funke irgendwie falsch
liegen das will man sich ja gar nicht
ausmalen denkt man da gar nicht dran als
astronaut oder wie ist das in so einem
moment an
war ja ein solche sachen muss man schon
denken es ist jetzt nicht ganz so
plakativ vielleicht das waren jetzt
denken würde ruhig ich habe jetzt die
rakete unter mir die explodiert bestimmt
gleich sondern man geht das natürlich
logischer an und nüchterne also man hat
einen plan b für alle fälle das heißt
selbst wenn es zu diesem schlimmsten
fall kommen würde und die rakete
explodiert auf der sportplattform den
treibstoff drin ist dann hat man ein
rettungssystem dass die kapsel sofort
wegkatapultiert das funktioniert
automatisch die größte angeschnallt drin
die hat da überhaupt keinen einfluss
mehr darauf die wird einfach gerettet
von diesem system und das ist in dem
fall dann tatsächlich keine
lebensbedrohliche situation dann mehr
wenn die kolander weg ist das heißt man
hat immer einen plan b auch im weltraum
ist uns wichtig dass man weiß was zu tun
ist wenn ein feuer ausbricht wenn ein
leck in der station ist dass man darauf
vorbereitet ist und dann nur kann man
das auch relativ entspannt angehen okay
das ist ja schon mal beruhigend auch zu
wissen und es wusste mit sicherheit auch
nicht jeder unserer user die wir an der
stelle auch noch mal gerne auffordern
mitzumachen fragen zu schicken
kommentare sondern ernst hat das auch
gemacht per mail mein sohn bruno sieben
jahre würde gerne wissen wie sich die g
kräfte beim start an fühlen und was vom
gefühl her schlimmer ist statt butter
landung vielen dank fürs beantworten
ja danke bruno für die tolle frage ist
tatsächlich eine interessante sache weil
man vorher auch wenn man noch nie
geflogen ist es gar nicht so genau weiß
wie sich das anfühlt man ist zwar in der
zentrifuge man probiert das mal aus aber
dann wie es dann wirklich ist wenn man
in dieser pakete sitzt und die einen
dann acht minuten lang mit diesem schub
in den weltraum beschleunigt und hoch
wie das schon also ich fand es
beeindruckend und ehrlich gesagt ich bin
ja so eine rasche früher immer eine
kleine achterbahnfahrt und vielleicht
bruno du ja aus als hättest du die frage
bestimmt nicht so gestellt dann macht es
eigentlich sogar ganz spaß also ich fand
das gar nicht unangenehm in diesen
sitzreihen gedrückt zu werden das ist so
dass man ja in diesem sitz quasi so
einer schale sitzt das heißt man man hat
gar nicht so große kräfte die einen
irgendwie verbiegen versuchen sondern
die drücken ein am anfang relativ
sanften am schluss dann doch mit
ordentlich schub in diesem sitzreihen
wenn man hat schwierigkeiten die arme zu
heben wenn man zum beispiel irgendwelche
kontrollelemente bedienen muss wenn man
irgendwie ans pult greifen muss dann ist
natürlich schon wirklich schwierig bei
viereinhalb g oder dann noch mehr wein
beim wiedereintritt aber abgesehen davon
macht es auch spaß es gibt natürlich
unheimlich viele aspekte die wir jetzt
gerne mit ihnen besprechen würden wir
kommen noch mal auf einen anderen elon
musk zum beispiel engagiert sich im all
wir hatten in spacex angesprochen ebenso
aber auch jeff bezos oder auch richard
branson das sind die drei bekanntesten
milliardäre allesamt sie alle treiben
die kommerzielle raumfahrt voran um
daraus eben dann auch irgendwann eine
geschäftsidee zu entwickeln ein
geschäftsmodell das bringt uns zur frage
von marco b punkt es über youtube wie
bewerten sie denn den immer größer
werdenden sektor der privaten raumfahrt
haben sie dazu eine meinung
ja das ist ein sehr wichtiges thema das
wird in der zukunft tatsächlich den
erdorbit bestimmen also die
kommerziellen firmen werden da einfach
viel mehr werden die nasa plant er zum
beispiel jetzt auch gar keine
institutionelle raumstation mehr also
eine von den weltraum agentur geführten
sondern das wird dann nach und nach in
die hände der kommerziellen firmen
gegeben da geht es nicht darum dass
milliardäre aus spaß im weltraum fliegen
sondern tatsächlich um handfeste
wissenschaftliche technologische
interesse neben aber auch mit auch
weltraumtourismus das ist ein wichtiger
punkt der ich selbst habe ja auch schon
mehrmals gesagt ich finde es gut wenn
jeder von uns menschen immer die
möglichkeit hat den weltraum zu fliegen
und da kommen wir ein stück näher das
wird noch eine weile dauern aber
letztendlich begründet sich die
kommerzielle raumfahrt in weise wie sich
die die luftfahrt vor 100 jahren
gefunden hat da ist es wichtig für uns
europäer dass wir da mit dabei sind dass
wir das nicht verpassen dass wir da auch
bei dieser bei diesem jahr neu bei
dieser neuen landschaft in erd orbit die
richtige rolle ausfüllen das heißt wir
müssen uns jetzt darum kümmern was ist
wenn es die iss mal nicht mehr gibt wir
denken wir können sie noch bis 2030
betreiben vielleicht auch ein bisschen
länger aber irgendwann ist schluss damit
und da müssen wir gut aufgestellt sein
und da gehst jetzt die richtigen weichen
zu stellen also durchaus ein plädoyer
für den privaten sektor in der raumfahrt
die kosten sind ja auch erheblich also
ungefähr 150 milliarden us-dollar so
schätzt man sind bislang auf gelaufen
für den erhalt den aufbau der iss aber
die gibt's natürlich jetzt auch schon
mehrere jahrzehnte
aber sie würden auch ganz klar sagen
also die experimente die dort oben
gemacht werden weil er mag es auch den
einen oder anderen geben dass ich sage
dir was bringen die dann eigentlich
überhaupt die sind schon sehr wichtig
dass das oben durchgeführt werden kann
ja selbstverständlich das haben wir auch
untersuchen lassen von allen möglichen
unabhängigen filmen die da versucht
haben wir also eine kosten nutzen
rechnung aufzustellen und da hat man
auch gesehen dass jeder euro den wir
investieren und das ist pro
bürger bürgerin ist das ungefähr 1 euro
50 im jahr also ungefähr ein cappuccino
im jahr den wir da investieren leider
nur eigentlich denn wir sollten mehr
investieren aber jeder euro den wir da
reinstecken kommt zweieinhalbfache
zurück in für unsere gesellschaft das
ist extrem wichtig für uns in der
technologie in der forschung in allen
möglichen bereichen auch in der
inspiration der nächsten generation
wurde natürlich in handfesten
wissenschaftlichen experimenten wenn sie
daran denken wir machen soweit wir da
oben jetzt matthias wirth experimente
durchführen zum alterung von
muskelzellen
muskeldystrophie
krankheiten werden wir daher forschung
das sind alles dinge speziell diese
experimente können wir nur im weltraum
durchführen einfach wegen dieser
einzigartigen bedingungen dort weil
wieder ganz rein in die zellen ganz pur
in die zellen reinschauen können und
aber die ergebnisse die sind für alle
von uns wichtig die wir hier unten leben
zum beispiel auch im bereich der
materialwissenschaften da geht es um
neue materialien zu finden für motoren
für flugzeugtriebwerke die viel
treibstoff sparender sind vielleicht
transformatoren die stromsparen
zement dass weniger co2 ausstoß
extrem wichtig sind für uns kommen wir
gleich noch zu sprechen vielen dank
schon mal bis hierhin wir wollen dann
gerne auch an dieser stelle nochmal den
nachfolger ein bisschen unter die lupe
nehmen gerade haben wir ihn ja schon in
seinem statement gehört matthias maurer
meine kollegin meike verlangt die hat
ihn sich noch mal etwas genauer
angeschaut bzw stellt ihn uns jetzt noch
mal etwas genauer vor
es ist seine mission matthias maurer 51
jahre alt saarländer
jahre lang hat er sich vorbereitet unter
anderem mit überlebenstraining in
extremsituationen maurer kann dna
analysieren geräte reparieren und sogar
zähne ziehen falls die einmal bei seinen
kolleginnen und kollegen auf der iss
schwierigkeiten bereiten sollten er wird
der zwölfte deutsche im all sein der
vierte deutsche auf der iss und der
erste deutsche an bord einer kruden
raumkapseln im all warten viele aufgaben
auf ihn er wird über 100
wissenschaftliche und technologische
experimente durchführen besondere
trainingsanzüge testen strahlen messen
beton untersuchen die internationale
raumstation iss ein labor wie kein
anderes hier können phänomene in der
schwerelosigkeit getestet werden das
kann etwa für die medizin interessant
sein
aber auch die erde haben die astronauten
stets im blick und damit auch
gletscherschmelze höchsten aus
breitungen wetterphänomene
ein halbes jahr wird maurer auf der iss
bleiben und wenn er neben all den
experimenten dazu kommt diesen blick
genießen
dieser blick ist auf jeden fall
beeindruckend jetzt hoffen wir mal dass
matthias maurer da oben keine zähne
ziehen muss thomas jarzombek von der cdu
darauf raumfahrt beauftragte der
bundesregierung er beschreibt maurer als
multitalent und universalgenie weil er
unter anderem eben auch mit chinesischen
und russischen equipment umgehen können
teilweise auch die sprachen spricht
klingt ja ziemlich beeindruckend
hören sie mich noch herr gerst können
sie nicht verstehen ja sie waren ganz
kurz weg jetzt auch das ja also ich
wollte gerade noch mal sagen kennen sie
denn herrn maurer persönlich was ist das
für ein typ wir haben gerade gehört er
hat offenbar einiges drauf spricht
verschiedene sprachen kann mit
internationalem equipment umgehen wie
haben sie ihn bislang erlebt
ja wir sind natürlich kollegen und auch
befreundet wir kennen uns schon seit
2008 sogar am viel zusammengearbeitet
und ja ich bin mir sicher er sehr gut
vorbereitet dass er hat er ist sehr viel
training gehabt auch mit seiner crew
zusammen und da ist das schon auf diese
mission so gut vorbereitet wie es geht
also das muss man auf jeden fall so
sagen wir kennen natürlich als
astronauten oft komplimente wir seien
irgendwelche genies oder so ich denke
das ist so ein bisschen verhalten da das
hat mir selbst auch heute schon gesagt
er will kein superheld sein ich will
auch kein superheld sein und das ist
auch wichtig dass wir nicht als solche
dargestellt werden weil sie sind ganz
normale menschen und ich glaube wenn man
das so überhöht dann schaffen dass da
selbst ein bisschen ein problem weil wir
dann kein nachwuchs finden weil alle
denken wie ich auch damals das habe ich
sowieso nicht drauf weil da muss man ja
superheld sein und das haben wir besucht
jetzt auch zu ändern so kommunikation
beim letzten werden letzten
bewerbungsrunde für astronautinnen und
astronauten war dann so die resonanz so
groß
22.500 leute dass wir gesehen haben dass
diese faszination für für die
weltraumfahrt da ist und ich glaube da
gehört dazu dass man den leuten auch
ehrlich sagt wir sind keine superhelden
und genie sondern wir sind ganz normale
menschen aber auf jeden fall ist
matthias ein toller typ also wir
verstehen uns sehr gut und ich bin mir
sicher er wird seine aufgabe da oben
hervorragend erledigen allen habe fragte
uns über youtube was macht denn matthias
maurer eigentlich für experimente auf
der iss ein paar haben wir schon gerade
im beitrag auch gesehen also soweit ich
weiß gibt ja unter anderem auch um
baustoff beton mischungen zum beispiel
für das weltall mit denen man dann den
aufbau von behausungen zum beispiel auf
mond oder mars möglich machen könnte das
scheint so ein spezial steckenpferd auch
von ihm zu sein denn er kommt ja aus der
material technik
ja da kennt er sich sehr gut mit aus
aber dazu muss man auch mal sagen es
geht ja nicht nur darum dass wir beton
für den weltraum bauen sondern dass wir
eben auch beton und zement besser
verstehen auf der erde der ist ja ein
riesiger beitrag geber zum co2 haushalt
also das heißt da gibt es viele
emissionen von co2 das heißt wenn wir
die zementherstellung verbessern können
in irgendeiner weise und da co2
einsparen dann ist das ein riesiger
hebel den wir dann ansetzen können und
somit für das klima was gutes tun können
und das ist eben bei vielen experimenten
so die sie jetzt auch schon erwähnt
haben dass es der anwendung gibt für den
weltraum das ist wichtig weil wir wollen
ja auch ein schritt weiter im weltraum
rausgehen es geht weiter zum mond und
zum mars das ist wichtig weil wir die
erforschung müssen weil da sehr viel
interessantes zu entdecken geist und
auch gefahren vielleicht vom weltraum
drohen die wird von dort aus besser
verstehen können aber es geht eben auch
immer darum bei diesen experimenten was
zur erde mit zurückzubringen und das ist
wirklich das schöne daran das macht
wirklich viel spaß dass auch dann zu
sehen wenn man gelandet ist nach seiner
mission mit den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern zu sprechen und zu
erfahren was das bewirkt hat und da ja
das ist wirklich das gibt es hunderte
experimente über 30 auch aus deutschland
also deutschland ist da vorn mit dabei
traditionell ich hoffe das bleibt auch
so und ja das immer wieder toll dass
mitzubekommen da noch eine frage von
meike es maurer ist ja einer der wenigen
astronauten die zum außen ansatz sowohl
ein us amerikanischen als auch einen
russischen raum anzug tragen können was
ist denn so kompliziert an diesen
anzügen was ist der unterschied
ja diese raumanzüge das sind wie kleine
raumschiffe selbst das sieht man denen
nicht unbedingt an sieht ja auch so ein
mensch in groß und nicht allen menschen
aber da hinten drin ist extrem
komplizierte technik und die natürlich
dann auch leicht gebaut sein muss
weniger energie brauchen darf und
deswegen sind solche raumanzüge relativ
empfindlich aber eben auch dann draußen
müssen sie robust seien gegen die
gefahren die von draußen drohen wenn man
als eigenes kleines raumschiff dann die
raumstation verlässt ich habe das ja im
jahr 2014 gemacht
amerikanische anzug ich habe
gleichzeitig auch damals auch schon
trainiert für den russischen anzug ich
hätte da auch die zertifizierung um
diese
ausstiege auch im russischen modul
durchzuführen da kannst dann nicht dazu
ich hoffe dass matthias diese chance
bekommt es geht ja um den europäischen
robotischen arm den er da ein wein soll
dann muss er ein paar dinge außen in
betrieb nehmen damit er richtig gut
funktionieren kann und da würde ich mich
total freuen wenn er das wenn er die
gelegenheit bekommen würde mit einem
russischen kollegen da rauszugehen unter
einer man fragt uns sehr geehrter herr
gast kann man von der iss die sterne am
himmel genauso sehen wie von der erde
aus oder sind sie überhaupt nicht zu
sehen über eine antwort würde ich mich
herzlich freuen
aber lasst euch für eine frage das war
für mich auch immer eine wichtige sache
daraus zu schauen und nicht nur nach
unten zu schauen weil natürlich als
astronaut man die erde darunter sich und
die sieht einen natürlich mag ich an den
blick und dann hat auch viel zu
entdecken aber irgendwann ist es auch
zeit mal den blick wieder nach oben zu
nehmen und draußen schauen die sterne
anzuschauen und ich habe da auch
versucht die zu fotografieren und ich
habe wirklich beeindrucken sichten da
gehabt also auf die milchstraße die
sieht man plötzlich viel klarer als von
der erde aus einfach weil keine
atmosphäre dazwischen ist die sterne
sind so klar und so hell wenn man eine
mond lose nacht hat also selbst auf der
raumstation gibt's nächste nacht ist ja
der teil wenn man hinter der erde
vorbeifliegen da gibt es aber nächte wo
man den mond gleichzeitig noch raten
vollmond der ein an leuchtet und dann
gibt es eben manche von diesen nacht
über fügen wo denn wo man den mond nicht
sieht und wenn man wenn der nicht da ist
dann sind die ferne so hell dass sie die
so deutlich sehen dass es dass so viele
da sind dass sie die konstellationen
nicht mehr erkennen können nicht lernt
sagen die kann man nicht mehr selbst in
großen wagen den jeder von uns am himmel
erkennen kann den sieht man dann nicht
mehr einfach war so viele sterne da sind
und die funkeln auch nicht weil die
sterne auf der erde nur deshalb funkeln
weil die atmosphäre dazwischen ist das
haben wir da oben nicht das einzige mal
wenn die funken ist wenn man hinter die
erde fliegt und der stern dann durch die
atmosphäre innerhalb von einer sekunde
untergeht in dem moment wenn man das
stell dich doch noch durch die
atmosphäre sieht dann funkelt er ganz
kurz wunderbar also die fragen an sie
sind nahezu endlos die hier auflaufen
wir könnten stundenlang wir müssen uns
ein bisschen kurz erfassen einem finde
ich auch noch ganz interessant was
machen denn die astronauten in ihrer
freizeit auf der iss wie sehr geht man
sich vielleicht auch mit der zeit auf
die nerven weil man muss ja auch
bedenken mauer soll zum beispiel im ein
halbes jahr da oben bleiben was macht
man dagegen also dass man da kein
lagerkoller bekommt
ja viel freizeit hat man leider da oben
nicht so wir arbeiten schon so von
morgens um sieben bis abends um sie
herum dann gibt es noch viel zu tun auch
administratives ja leider auch auf der
raumstation muss man e mails schreiben
arbeitsplätze das ist leider so dann hat
man so also nach wenn man die zeit fürs
essen abzieht und für die körperhygiene
und für alles hat man so ungefähr so
eine stunde freizeit am tag und dann
bringt man natürlich gerne damit man aus
dem fenster zu schauen aber eben auch
mit der familie zu telefonieren und mit
den freunden man will ja in kontakt
bleiben mit den menschen auf dem boden
das heißt man hat gar nicht so viel
freizeit lagerkoller gab es bei uns
wirklich überhaupt nicht die raumstation
iss ja wirklich groß wir waren da zu
sechst bzw zu dritt da ist dann eher so
dass man mal fast den ganzen tag lang
irgendwie irgendwo arbeitet wo man die
anderen gar nicht sieht man froh dem er
sich zum essen mal wieder trifft jetzt
bei matthias wird zum bisschen anders
sein der hat zehn kollegen und
kolleginnen da oben dann wenn er oben
ist und da wird so ein bisschen voller
da muss man auch schauen dass man zum
beispiel die trainingsgeräte fürs
laufbahn dass man da ist ich genau an
seine zeiten hält da kann man nicht noch
mal ein extra kilometer laufen das wird
für ihn schon ein bisschen schwieriger
aber die die stimmung an bord das ist
immer so natürlich auch von all meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen die sehr
freundschaftlich man lacht viel zusammen
man hilft sich aus man macht sich ein
cappuccino und wirft ihn mal rüber im
geschlossenen paket natürlich ihr mann
gibt sich
wenn man teilt den den persönlichen
schokolade vorrat almer das riesig viel
spaß gemacht und deswegen glaube ich
kommt sowas wie lagerkoller da er
weniger auf das sein was worauf man
achten muss wenn man mal zum mars liegt
in einem kleinen raumschiff eine lange
lange zeit da ist so was viel wichtiger
das dauert wohl noch ein wenig aber das
ist ganz interessant was sie gerade
sagen was das atmosphärische angeht denn
auch maurer hat sich dazu geäußert
er sagt wichtig ist die zusammenarbeit
der nation im all wenn wir außerhalb der
erde arbeiten wollen dann müssen wir
auch als menschheit auf unserem
heimatplaneten zusammenhalten dass seine
botschaft die iss habe gezeigt dass man
ein projekt gemeinsam stellen könne
welches die menschheit eine und
vertrauen schaffe so maurer in einem
interview und da meine frage auch an sie
das ist ja schon ein bisschen politisch
fast philosophisch sehen sie das ähnlich
die iss sozusagen auch ein bisschen als
friedensprojekt
ja auf alle fälle das ist eine der
wichtigen gründe warum es die es
überhaupt gibt wenn man sie es genau
anschaut wenn man es genau analysiert
dann ist die iss als politisches projekt
gestartet worden um frieden zu schaffen
zwischen ost und west wir dürfen nicht
den fehler machen dass wir dieses
projekt nur dadurch rechtfertigen dass
wir sagen wir machen der wissenschaft
und technologie erprobung das würde der
sache zu kurz kommen es gibt weitere
extrem wichtige elemente dabei das ist
eben eins davon die internationale
zusammenarbeit das ist ja so ein
bisschen soft power weil wenn man
zusammen in so einem projekt drin steckt
wohl für alle wichtig ist dass wir
zusammenarbeiten damit jeder diesen
nutzen daraus ziehen kann das hält dass
das schweißen zusammen und dann hält man
eben auch auch wenn es mal politisch
minister besser zusammen das haben wir
gesehen 2014 bei unserer mission das ist
toll zu sehen dass es gibt weitere
elemente wir haben natürlich auch ein
auftrag die kommerzialisierung
durchzuführen dass wir unserer industrie
in europa auch die möglichkeit geben da
weiter ihre erfahrungen zu halten und
weiter aufzubauen und dann viel
wichtiger für mich noch ist es die
inspiration die wir damit durch
astronauten und astronauten auf der
raumstation weitergeben können an die
nächste generation für mich ist das
größte kompliment wenn
eltern zu mir kommen und sagen hey meine
tochter will jetzt astronauten werden
oder ingenieurin oder wissenschaftlerin
weil sie bei zum beispiel bei der
sendung mit der maus gesehen hat oder
weil sie den matthias maurer gesehen hat
im fernsehen das ist für uns eines der
größten komplimente dies überhaupt geben
kann schön es gibt einen ziemlich
bewegenden o ton von ihnen den sie auch
aus der iss zum zustand unseres planeten
gesagt haben wir wollen noch mal kurz
rheinland
wenn ich so auf den planeten runter
schaut dann denke ich dass ich mich bei
euch wohl leider entschuldigen muss im
moment sieht es so aus als ob wir meine
generation euch den planeten nicht
gerade im besten zustand hinterlassen
werden ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
nicht bei euch als die generation in
erinnerung bleiben die ihre
lebensgrundlage egoistisch und
rücksichtslos
zerstört hat
[Musik]
ja durchaus selbstkritische worte
natürlich im namen einer ganzen
generation und affleck schreibt lassen
sich die auswirkungen des klimawandels
von dort oben beobachten
was ehrlich wir können das sehen wir
können sehen sehen
beobachten die ausgetrocknet sind ich
lag jetzt wegen dem wort aber das ist
eigentlich überhaupt nicht lustig dass
er traurig wir können
eigenblut auf den ozean sehen wir können
sehen wie die wüsten weiter
fortschreiten das ist von oben sichtbar
aber das ist trotzdem noch zu kurz
gedacht also wir können uns nicht nur
darauf verlassen auf die dinge die wir
mit bloßen augen sehen sondern wir
müssen tatsächlich auch den
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
glauben die uns genau sagen was sich
ändert mit unserem planeten da ist ja
auch ein bisschen unsere aufgabe bei der
bei der esa mit dem kopernikus
erdbeobachtung system mit dem wir
weltweit führen sind damit drauf zu
schauen weil viele klima variablen nur
aus dem weltraum zu beobachten sind zwar
nicht von bloßem auge sondern mit
elektronischen augen das ist sehr sehr
wichtig und da spielen wir natürlich
eine rolle und da geht es ihm auch darum
sie haben es vorhin erwähnt kommerzielle
raumfahrt mehr raketenstarts da ist zum
beispiel auch unsere aufgabe dass wir an
antrieben forschen die umweltfreundlich
sind die dänen nicht noch mehr co2
verursachten die nachhaltig sind das ist
wichtig dass man wenn man den schritt
nach vorn geht dass man da auch dann das
nachhaltig tut gut dass ich es auch
nochmal ansprechen das natürlich auch
immer wieder einen kritikpunkt dass man
natürlich auch durch die raumfahrt nicht
zusätzlich sozusagen für belastungen
sorgen will nochmals vielen dank an
dieser stelle auch an unsere user wir
kriegen wirklich viele viele zuschriften
wir sind froh dass wir einige abarbeiten
konnten vielleicht als letzte frage wie
fand ich sehr schön von sexy youtube
fühlt es sich anders an wenn man nachts
die sterne sieht nachdem man im weltall
war
das ist eine schöne frage die ich
tatsächlich glaube ich noch nie gestellt
bekommen und ja das fühlt sich anders an
wenn man im weltraum war weil man
nach oben schaut und das nicht mehr so
ein ort ist der ganz fremd ist und weit
weg und man sich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen kann wie er ist sondern er
fühlt sich ein bisschen vertraut an so
komisch das ist und natürlich klar dass
es wieder vielleicht auch so ein
bisschen menschlicher arroganz wir waren
400 km da draußen die sterne sind
milliarden von lichtjahren entfernt das
heißt wir haben noch nicht mal an der
oberfläche dar angekratzte auf dieser
distanz aber dennoch wenn man dort mal
war dann fühlt sich das so an als ob man
war so ein bisschen zu hause war es ist
ja auch so dass die iss für mich nach
einem jahr doch zu einem zuhause
geworden ist und das auch ein grund
warum ich denke das ist sehr wichtig
wäre für alle von uns irgendwann mal
diese perspektive auch an von oben
runter zu schauen und das große und
ganze immer mal wieder zu sehen dass man
auch wenn man ein problem hat auf der
erde klein ob groß dass man dann doch
eher dazu neigt einfach mal einen
schritt zurückzugehen und so ein problem
von außen zu betrachten das wäre im
prinzip das perfekte schlusswort ich
will trotzdem eine frage noch stellen
das interessiert auch viele inspire über
youtube hallo alex haben sie auf dem weg
zur iss unbekannte flugobjekte gesehen
unbekannte flugobjekte habe ich nicht
gesehen das wäre auch komisch ich glaube
selbst wenn es eines gäbe ich glaube
nicht dass die mit grünen antennen und
verfolgen und und irgendwelche
fliegenden untertassen und
hinterherschicken ich denke aber das ist
trotzdem ein guter hintergrund ist
dieser frage weil die stellen wir uns
jahre gibt es leben da draußen im
universum das halt nicht jetzt eher in
form von irgendwelchen außerirdischen
mit grünen antennen existiert sondern
tatsächlich realistischerweise könnte es
das geben aufmaß in einer form die wir
vielleicht noch gar nicht kennen oder
verstehen deswegen ist es auch so
wichtig dass wieder hinreißend haben wir
auch ein projekt das exomars projekt bei
der esa wo wir tatsächlich genau das
herausfinden wollen gibt es eventuell
existierendes leben oder ausgestorbenes
leben auf dem mars wenn wir das finden
würden das wäre phänomenal 1 1 komplette
eine komplette zäsur in der menschlichen
geschichte und auch viele so viel wenn
man es zu nehmen wir wüssten dann wenn
wir auf dem mars spuren von leben finden
das wahrscheinlich das universum vor
leben nur so blöd einfach rein
statistisch gesehen dass eine der
interessantesten fragen die ich mir
vorstellen kann die wir vielleicht in
unserer lebenszeit noch lösen können
also es bleibt spannend das kann man
wohl sagen es war sehr spannend mit
ihnen alexander gerst heute zu sprechen
zwei tage vor dem start der nächsten
mission eine richtung iss wir hoffen
dass alles gut geht wir danken ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch und wollen
natürlich nicht versäumen darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir dann am
sonntagmorgen 6 uhr 45 live dabei sind
beim lift off der mission cosmic ist so
heißt diese mit matthias maurer und wir
können fast garantieren das frühe
aufstehen das wird sich lohnen euch
allen vielen dank fürs mitmachen es war
toll wie die beteiligung hier war sehr
viele zuschriften freuen uns sehr
darüber euch allen einen schönen abend
und ein schönes wochenende und am
sonntag gerne 645 dabei sein